nice
okay so we are live gentlemen we are
back we are back for
episode number 17 of the podcast with a
jam-packed episode
uh you know it feels like it was just
yesterday when trump said he had coveted
and we talked about it on podcasts but
we've never talked about the
uh right getting covered on the podcast
it's one of those things that the new
cycle never ends for that it's just one
big warp of news just bombarding you
constantly
it's it's ongoing it's non-stop and we
got a lot of things to cover
uh one is trump getting covet and the
reaction from the left the middle and
the right
which we'll talk about all shocking too
right no question about it hard to
imagine
and and obviously today we have one very
very exciting big announcement to make
that we're excited about uh
sharing with you uh we'll talk about
what's going on between armenian
azerbaijan which is
uh ongoing now it's officially on the
ninth day we got a lot of things to talk
about with that part
regal cinema suspends operation at all
u.s location closing
could affect 40 000 jobs then we have
levi's is jumping into the 32 billion
dollar resale market with its own
program
for warren jeans and jackets uh jp
morgan to pay 920 million dollars 661
jobs added to the economy last month as
of october 1st we'll talk about the
unemployment side
john mcafee out of all the people john
michael has been on vitamin before yeah
i'd like to hear your opinion on this
john mcafee indicted for tax evasion
weird dude
yeah qualified qualified weirdo i mean
you know this guy or not oh yeah totally
the fact that they found him is is
shocking
he's a league of his own that guy is in
a league of his own
uh and then something's going on with
maduro he's about to get a billion
dollars the debate that's taking place
with kamala hurst and mike pence
melania trump caught on tape swearing in
response to children separated at border
and uh we'll actually watch to do that
together and get a reaction that one i'm
really curious to know what you guys
gonna say
and there's a few other things going on
that ireland's court ruled that subway
sandwich bread
is not legal make sure you get to that
one today no no not legally
do not tell me brett yes i love missing
somebody brad
and then snl did an interesting uh
debate remake
of what took place uh recently so i say
let's just get right into it you know
with
uh movies first and we'll let that we'll
let the audience build up before we get
started guys if you're
back with us on this podcast we
appreciate your
coming back and being with us put the
thumbs up and share the podcast so we
can get uh
into the different topics here i know we
got uh dorian give him yeah
oh yeah dorian listen i've never
celebrated the heat winning
this is the first time in my life i've
been excited about somebody beating the
lakers in the finals
yeah i was rooting for butler triple
double i think it's a series
i really do i mean they're back riley's
got them i'm just waiting for the
breaking news that bam is coming back
goron's coming back yeah shout out to my
uh i think this is out there i think the
strategy is you got to get 18 foul
troubles that's simple
you got to get him in foul trouble sure
you get him in foul trouble early then
you got a shot you don't
right you don't it's that simple and
force the lakers to shoot threes because
they're not always going to make them
that's a good point that's a good point
so let's talk about regal cinemas okay
regal cinema suspends operation at all
u.s locations on monday
say they're closing 536 stores okay
on a lack of new releases the closing
will affect
40 000 regal employees uh the parent
companies
sign world plunge 40 in trading monday
after the announcement new york and
california markets
have remained closed this is the two
largest markets we are like a grocery
shop that doesn't have vegetables fruit
and meat
the ceo mookie grinding uh gersch said
in an interview we cannot operate for a
long time without a product some
hollywood studios have experimented with
shipping big big budget movies directly
online walt disney opted against
releasing its 200 million dollar mulan
remake
in u.s theaters and instead put the
movie on stream and service for about 30
think about that i mean you're thinking
about liking we're going to go to the
theater they said forget about we're not
going through it we go on a
stream of service for 30 bucks but with
only two-thirds of domestic theaters
able to open because of various state
and local guidelines the consumers
apparently still wary of going to
theaters
the 200 million dollar movie grows just
45 million dollars in the us and canada
and the performance led hollywood
studios to recall from releasing costly
films for now
so your thoughts you've been in this
business for a while what are you
thinking about i feel horrible
for the uh for the business i really do
because i'll tell you right now they're
done
we're used to not going to theaters is
anybody looking forward to going to a
theater
i didn't even like the experience before
covid i really didn't especially when
you realize you can get all this at home
now
and these streaming services have
pounced i mean they are so lucky
i mean the the timing could not be
better for them do you see what the
stock price did for the
cinemark the number one cinema chain in
britain it went from 275 before the
pandemic to 52 bucks right now
that whole industry is in such serious
trouble right now and here's the here's
the saddest thing for them
like the ceo said they can't link one
case of kovid
to go into a movie theater you know it'd
be one thing if you thought okay
my business my industry is responsible
for 10 000 people dying i get it right
but when there's not
one not one that they can really prove
person that's contracted
covered from going to a movie theater
it's got to be very very frustrating
same thing with bar owners and
you know museums and things like that
but i i don't
care about going to a theater again i
have no desire to
i don't like the experience to be honest
with you maybe i'll go once a year
because a i'd much rather watch it on my
own schedule and b
a lot of people at theaters annoy me
right and if i'm going to have two and a
half hours
everybody though that's that becomes a
question are you everybody yeah
because you're not everybody what's
going on no what i mean by this are you
everybody is what what i wonder
is uh i hear you good by the way just so
you know maybe you don't hear yourself
yeah yeah
i wonder if you are everybody sometimes
like i go to myself and i'll say
things like well who the hell's going to
buy coffee um
not a few billion people i could care
less about coffee i'm like you know what
that's exactly what's going on because
no one's drinking coffee
i don't know about uh what's going on
here and by the way
you may be right i'm not saying you're
wrong or you're right i'm just saying
i don't know if we're gone away from the
movies because of that or people are
just flat out scared to take their kids
to the theater are you a movie guy do
you go to the movies
with your family for me for years if you
ask my assistants
how did you know when pat came in from
watching a movie i would come
uh seven o'clock to the office i'd work
till 10 o'clock i'd go across the street
i'd watch a movie i'd come back she says
where were you at i got popcorn all over
my food
and i would go and watch movies with my
80 year old friends oh that's funny
you know pat here's the thing i think
america if this had lasted three weeks
a month and a half it's a different
thing but habits change
in the span of six months and if you
take the experience of going to a
theater away from people and they find
an alternative
it's even if it's 30 that don't go back
it's going to be really really
detrimental
what do you think about it i mean the
the whole industry just needs to adapt
and survive so you see that a lot of
these uh
drive-in movie theaters are popping up
now tom hit on the fact that
he'd rather stay home obviously you got
netflix you got
quibby you got disney plus and you got
all these other cbs and
hulu and everything popping up so for
instance i don't go to the movies unless
i'm with a girl and she's like i really
want to go to the movies and then when
we go to the movies
we go to these like fancy couch sitting
type he's paying thirty dollars into a
morning or all the way to bed in the
corner
you know in front of him the
way up top the old popcorn trick we know
that one um
but the the
busted but the these
let me get that popcorn go ahead they
they need to adapt and survive
basically i don't see anyone just
showing up sitting in your typical seat
other than paula scar cigar our famous
talent director he's the same
uh movie over and over again he buys
like the the month pass and he just goes
to the movies money on that guy
they lose money on that guy yeah you
gotta adapt and survive because the
the the game has certainly changed and
um
i think tom's right i don't know if it's
going to bounce back here's the bigger
question who's deciding all this
i fly here right every week planes are
full all right you got someone
closer than me and adam sitting for
three and a half hours on a plane
right but but then now a theater you
can't go to a movie theater you can't go
to a
football game i think that's what would
kill me if i was in one of these
industries that's getting crushed
because who the hell is making up these
rules and they're not
fair and they're not consistent so man
it just doesn't even say why can't you
have social distancing in the theater
and at least try to open them up
well a couple things i don't know if you
saw what uh cuomo and de blasio said
again
whatever it was i'm sure it was great
well it was it was again they're
shutting down
restaurants which now it's at a point
right now where they're thinking 50 of
restaurants are going to just be
gone yeah and that's not even your
exaggeration oh no audit said that that
could happen
that's that's an audit saying that's
that's going to happen and that's new
york city like you're talking about
you go to new york city to go to
restaurants it's known for its
restaurants right okay 50
is going to be gone de blasio came out
and they're saying they're they're about
both him and cuomo are on the same page
about shutting down churches
if they don't follow guidelines they're
going to shut down churches
non-essential businesses are again
going to be shut down because their
cases are going up they're not talking
about how many death but their time on
how many cases that's going up in new
york
all that stuff's taking place and then
again he was asked
again he was asked how about protesting
and he says well that's
it's a very sensitive time in history
right de blasio de blasio it's a very
sensitive i was in my interview in july
no no this just happened we did it again
this week this is your implant this is
yesterday we're talking about the last
uh 24-48 hours this is kind of where i
go with this look
when i lived in iran and there was war
and we were bombed on
okay and we went from city to city to
city to city to city everything
it seemed gloomy like i don't even know
if you guys remember when the pandemic
first said maybe it was just me for
about a month or two dallas seemed
gloomy
when he went outside it was just clouds
were dark the energy
right it was just very weird the energy
was gone you were driving the freeway i
felt like i was in the movie i am legend
you know dry i'm waiting for my dog
not today no that you're a legend that's
a different story i like that by the way
so so i'm i'm going through it and i'm
looking at the streets i'm like look
what's going on here
you would see somebody you felt like you
were part of a rebellious community
everybody would put their hands up
you're like
man we're doing this but i tell you when
the war happened
and it went away the first thing people
wanted
was a form of entertainment the first
thing people want is a form of
entertainment the first thing
it didn't matter if you wanted to go on
vacation it didn't matter if you wanted
to go to movies at denmark if you wanted
to go to park
the entire family desperately needed a
vacation i'll give you a perfect example
of what happened to us a couple months
ago
so march i mean february the the the
coronavirus becomes a little bit more
public march
official shutdown 1314 starts seeing
sports and league shutting down
yeah and then afterwards i have a zoom
with our guys and our
guys don't have makeup on i'm like wait
a minute the girl that always has makeup
on looks like a tent all the time she
has no makeup on
our guys wouldn't even face the camera
they were off the camera and i'm doing
daily
calls with our vps just to kind of see
how they're feeling he said well pat
this kind of realists what's going on
that's what's going on i said great
we came together we worked obviously we
had the best quarter in the history the
company best month all of that stuff
that took place
but at the end of it after about three
four months our guys needed a break
so what did we do we had a break at the
breakers okay
very appropriate so we brought everybody
together
and you know what's the craziest thing
when everybody saw each other it was
emotional
yeah of course i mean they're like dude
i just wanted to see somebody yeah
how you doing how you doing how
everybody was talking to each other
connection
so i don't know if theaters are going to
go away because
theaters is the cheapest form of
entertainment for low income and middle
income families
that's simple and and i highly doubt
that it's going to go
away as easily as quickly as newspapers
as we thought it's going to be
i do think there's going to be a
transition quite frankly i don't think
we are at the point yet where these guys
gonna be
launching blockbuster movies on you know
you know
uh streaming services and all that stuff
there's still that experiment of going
to the movies
and and you know how the profit margins
work all the profit from movies are made
at movie theaters that's all concession
stance so
that is the experience i think they need
to be more creative about it we'll see
what's going to happen well and the
pressure's on hollywood too to crank out
some good content but you know what all
they care about is one thing
are the theaters open in china all right
that's where they're going to make their
money anyway
all right so here's the question yeah
right here's the question when's the
next time you guys are going to go see a
movie in a theater when is it
i went a couple weeks ago you went i
went a couple weeks when we watched
jurassic park for like the 50th time
except this time was the second time in
a movie theater
okay jurassic park i hope i don't go
again in the next three years minimum
maybe when i have grandkids
i have no desire to go to a theater no
you're kidding me and think about your
kids
oh i'm just so harsh on my kids denying
the movies no but that
you know it's all right um i just don't
like the experience just to be honest
with you
okay so we'll see what's gonna happen
and uh ladies i just want you to know
adam is still open to going to the
movies i don't want anybody upset
i will go just before you order the
popcorn with him ask him what is the
popcorn trick
because he may or may not release it you
know
mario and paul went to the movies
recently they they invited me and i
and i i bailed on them i bailed on them
i said guys do you
uh what movie was it were they going to
watch like there was like
one freaking movie that was out it was
like tenants coming to texas near you
damn it
have you seen this no i haven't it's the
same it's the only movie though that was
the movie that was supposed to save
hollywood this summer right and it just
bombed did it really bomb yeah
tremendously yeah okay all right what
story do we want to hit up next how
about we take
jobs okay 661 000 jobs added to the
economy last month
as of october 1st unemployment did from
8.4
to 7.9 which is good more than half the
jobs in march and april have now been
recovered that's pretty impressive more
than half the jobs
in march and april have now been
recovered that still remains 10.7
million jobs
that had a job before the pandemic still
don't have one at the current rate it
would take another 16 months
for things to get back to pandemic
levels thoughts okay i think these are
the easiest stats to manipulate right
now
in an election cycle because a there's
going to be a lot more numbers added to
that unemployment because of what just
happened with the airlines
and in the banking and there's a lot of
layoffs in the last couple weeks
the other thing too is how many of these
people and i believe there's a lot out
there
that are still cool not going back to
work because they're making enough money
on unemployment yeah or making more
money i think so as well
and i've talked to a lot of those people
you run into them and it's still an
issue so
um i think i think this is one of those
things where hey we're three four weeks
away from an election
they're going to use it however they
want i mean that is encouraging it's the
lowest level of unemployment since the
beginning of the pandemic
so hopefully it continues but i think
you know we're let's let's find out
where we are in december based on the
result of the election
you said you spoke to spoke to some
people that that are that
would prefer not to go back to work
because they're making more money
yeah collecting unemployment well that
that was true at one point up until the
the because obviously there's there was
the state
unemployment that on average is like 350
bucks
and then you had the federal
unemployment that kicked in and they
were giving everybody 600 bucks a week
two-thirds of people who were unemployed
were getting paid more to stay home than
to
go to work cool but that ended there's
been no stimulus deal in sight that
thing's gone
back and forth and starting and
restarting we'll see where that goes
so agreed people were getting paid to
stay home more
at one point that is not the case right
now um
people need to be looking for jobs i
mean people need to pivot there's going
to be some jobs like these movie theater
jobs that might not ever come back
certain industries that might not ever
come back you brought up something last
uh podcast you said how many jobs have
been created in the last 200 years
it was like a billion jobs three billion
three billion jobs yeah i underplayed
that one
three billion jobs so we've learned
anything during this pandemic we thought
everything's going to hell nothing's
going to happen
certain businesses are booming right uh
zoom
all-time highs yeah fiverr all-time high
i think certain industries all-time high
yeah things are gonna change that you
just gotta pivot careers if you need to
i think i think the conversation with
your kids need to start now
and meaning you know how uh uh parents
talk to their kids and they say oh
parents talk to their kids and they say
hey like i'm armenian assyrian you know
middle eastern when you grow up you're
going to be one of three things you're
either going to be an engineer you're
going to be a lawyer you're going to be
a doctor it's that simple
that's what it is they literally would
tell you that that's what you're
supposed to do
and would you disappoint them if you
didn't go that path that's exactly what
it is listen
until today even my mother till today
asks when are you going to get a college
degree i'm like mom whoever is the only
mom i'm doing okay i'm never going to
get a college degree right
but but this is where i'm going with
this that's where i'm going with this i
think it's the bigger topic
you know how you have uh parents are are
gonna have a few different topics with
their kids what's one of the topics
sex how are babies born okay and
everything i leave that's the wife by
the way you leave that to the wife i had
it very early i did
tikkon dylan he was four and six i sat
him down i said we were all naked in the
shower i said we all have danglings
okay that's what we have i said that
dangling
is gonna be your favorite toy for the
rest of your life i said that is
your toy that is nobody else's toy one
day
you're gonna find a female friend that's
gonna help you play with that toy but
that is yours
okay you don't play with his i don't
play with his you play with yours
you can touch yours you can do whatever
you want to do with yours you had this
conversation when they were four and six
four and six years old like i said i
leave that to my wife but let me explain
to you why because you know you have
kids coming over and girls are over and
they're like you know
curious and they're touching each other
and all this other you have to have
these conversations very early
and quite frankly nowadays with
everything that's going on if you don't
teach your kids about
a person coming to your kids and saying
hey this is a secret between me and you
no one's going to know our little secret
i'm going to give you this candy if you
don't have these conversations let me
tell you something you're thinking of
and then you you know indirectly can
talk about babies being born you have to
have these conversations with your kids
right
and as i'm doing this there's the drug
conversation
okay i've had the alcohol conversation
with my kids my kid every single time
we had a one of our friends that had an
alcohol problem and i had to take this
friend to
uh rehab all this other stuff and
another friend had to go bail him out
multiple friends have to build them out
from
from jail because of drug issues and
alcohol issues this has happened my
entire life everybody has a friend that
they've gone through drugging
i'll tell them i said do you know who
our president is yes who's our president
donald trump do you know what happened
to his older brother no daddy what
happened to him
his older brother died how did he die he
was an alcoholic
he drank alcohol yes he drank alcohol he
died from drinking alcohol yes
do you know dylan till today every time
he sees somebody drinking alcohol what's
the first thing he says
says are you drinking alcohol yes did
you know
president trump's older brother died
from alcohol he says it till today okay
amazing today he said public service now
watch what happens the other day dylan
says
daddy uh the other day friends were over
they opened that one closet we have a
lot of alcohol
what do we have all that alcohol for i
don't see you drinking it why do we have
it
tico says because alcohol is good when
you bleed you put alcohol on your wood
[Laughter]
give me a little rum and vodka love the
fact that he could save the day
so then we talk about drugs we talk
about a lot of drugs and why do people
use drugs
my kids are five six years old i'm
having these conversations with them
i think the one conversation parents
need to start having with their kids
is about their careers and i think it
needs to start very early
meaning sun think about
being a coder think about predictive
analytics
think about data think about skill sets
that are needed today think about hard
skills soft skills are hardcore needed
you got to teach your kids how to lead
respect and prove love
all of that stuff but you got to teach
your kids some real
good direction to go into engineer is
the way to go today
not lawyer or doctor it's engineer
it's how are you gonna go be a person
that knows coding a person that knows
analytics a person that knows things
like that
i understand the part where people say
well my kid is an art person
she wants to go to fine arts i totally
get it i don't say you have full control
about what your kids are going to do my
parents could have told me whatever they
could have told me i ended up selling
insurance
i guarantee you never in my life my mom
and dad sat me down and saying son
one day you have to sell insurance
because that's the way to go
you know so all i'm saying is these 661
000 jobs that are lost
and we're getting them back and
gradually we're going back up
parents have to talk to their kids about
what the future looks like
with another pandemic that comes down
because the standard's been set the next
president when a pandemic comes has to
shut down everything and when they do if
you don't learn from this mistake we
learn
which industries took the biggest hit
we're going to pay the price again
so families have to make the adjustments
themselves i think that's what needs to
take here's my question to the both of
you because you you're
you have a daughter who's what 14 yes
son 11
11 studs a little skater your kids are
dash dash eight six and eight
seven and okay totally understand like
the sexual conversation with the boys
the alcohol
i assume you let jen have the
conversation with your daughter
senna she's i mean i assume you don't
have that conversation with her i don't
know
but the business conversation what's the
appropriate age
that you should speak to your kids like
for me i don't have kids so this is just
being
presumptuous four six eight might be a
little early because i don't talk to
them about being an engineer i mean i
think i think from
you know you're wired differently some
people are just worried like if
if someone had told me to be an engineer
i would i would have been unemployed the
rest of my life i just wouldn't have
been able to figure it out you know
my brain just doesn't work that way um i
just try to encourage them in what
they're good at support them and you
know
they're finding their own i haven't also
a 22 year old daughter you know kuma
zumlati from pepperdine who's now a
teacher she's going to be a teacher so
she's student teaching so
you kind of let them follow their own
paths but support them
um but yeah communication 24 7 for us
that's what we do just so you know i'm
where tom's at yeah i'm 100 where tom's
at because i have three kids
each of them have different strengths
and different interests completely
different interests
but if i notice tom likes the camera
today
guess what media is not a bad route to
go today you know why what did we learn
to the pandemic with media media blew up
right
media blew up why what's the word what's
the first place we wanted to get the
news yeah
media people need information so so you
still can
help steer in some kind of a direction
and avoid
certain things that are just not going
to be happening unless if they're going
to find a way to disrupt so for example
i'd say
this is the conversation with the kids
and say uh tico i'll say so what do you
like about video games i like this about
video games i'd say
so tico how would you change this video
game to make it better and you say you
know what i would do
i would add this and i would add that
and i would add this
and i would add this to it that's great
how would you change this
i would do that and i would do this
everything goes to tell me how you would
improve this
okay hey by the way just so you know you
know newspapers are taking a big hit
this and they're taking a big hit what
would you do to change that they give
you that feedback
and you get them thinking about certain
industries to go into i'll say one thing
that um
i had no clue what i was going to be i
know my god you got a video you want to
show us i want to send it to kai
okay yeah okay do a
airdrop see if you can pick it up with
an airdrop dash skating
well this is my dash i was going to see
if this is bad advice can i tell dash to
be a pro
skateboarder he's only been skating
since december can you grab this this
guy's going to be a model forget about
this
he's going to be on a cover magazine go
ahead well i was just going to say that
one thing my dad would always tell me is
like
sales son you got to be in sales no
matter what it is you got to be in sales
you got to be in sales
my mom on the other hand zero business
savvy she would say
whatever you end up doing just be the
best version of yourself do whatever
whatever you want you can be a garbage
man be the guest best you know how your
mom
constantly tells you to yeah go to
school my mom to this day
still tells me i thought you were going
to be a rabbi why didn't you become
around my mom i don't even go to temple
i'm not into that you could be such a
good rabbi my people listen to you they
lie
i'm like mom the rabbi thing's done it's
not happening because she watched the
podcast she will she'll probably see
this but she's
she's going to be very upset that i'm
still she thinks i'm alright just so you
know mom i'm also disappointed he's not
a writer
i've been working on it for the longest
heartbroken when we couldn't
believe it the thing is he acts like one
all the time so that's gorgeous very
well
popcorn when he gets to popcorn but go
ahead
but just mom's gonna ask you what is the
popcorn i think i think something that
i've learned
is that you know again i don't have kids
but all my best friends have kids and
whatever
i think when you're young you start wide
right and then you have to at some point
use the funnel system so you being a
jack of all trades when you're
10 12 15 20 is fine but you need to hone
in you need to have a specific skill set
you need to be a specialist
i've heard you mention this a lot
specialist over a generalist
right yeah jack of all trades doesn't
cut it anymore you have to be good at
one thing and then once you're great at
one thing you can branch out from there
and i i i stress just be serious about
it if there's something that you're
passionate
about you just got to be serious about
it and attack it you know
very good feedback kai let's see dash by
the way just sorry about everybody has
to know this
let me put it to you this way i mean a
lot of kids i'm telling you i mean a lot
of kids i i got a lot of
kids that i love i got david david
vera's son
the kid called me the other day i had a
30-minute conversation with him on a
sunday he wants to write a book
one of my favorite kids we have in a
company had a lengthy conversation with
him
on how to write a book he's 11 years old
i'll talk to him by the way yeah
i mean he's a 11 year old kid wants to
write a book so excited about
you meet a lot of young kids that are
studs my nephew my niece
my niece the other day is telling me
about the economical challenges she's
seen with politics and
why you know she's concerned about what
direction we're going with politics and
then sean's having
when you see kids you know their studs
this kid
is a qualified stud dash if you're
listening to this
you know it as well we don't have to
even tell you that's the challenge with
this kid
he knows he's a qualified stop bruh
watch this
speech on sunday watch this
look at this you know what would happen
if i did that
it
he here's a crazy thing here's a crazy
thing
how old is he he's 11 and he's only been
skating i i didn't let him get a
skateboard i said there is no way in
hell you're getting a skateboard my
shonda and my wife were talking about
this the other night we're saying i
can't believe we just didn't decide
until christmas to let them have one
let me say one thing i learned from you
guys on what you did which was very
impressive
so we're having a lunch with you uh at
manhattan what was that place with
uh wonderful food yeah with our way to
ricky was it ricky ricardo what was the
waiter's name i think it was
ricardo he loved you yeah he he so he
kept coming to oh you got jokes you
think you're funny yeah yeah
david yeah yeah good job i had no no
chill whatsoever so but but here's what
happened while we're having lunch
and you guys are talking uh ivana
showed up right with an e ivano showed
up and with an e18 with a hey ivana
showed up
and she showed up with a friend we're
about to go to a different place
and then she leaves and then shonda
tells us you know that
she did an extensive uh intense six
weeks
uh uh what do you call it uh lifeguard
training i said why are you doing a live
car training well that's how we
let our kids go to the beach by
themselves and i sat there and i'm
thinking you know i came back just so
you know i told this to my sister i told
this my brother-in-law i told this to
jen i said
if we ever live near a beach that is the
only way i'm going to let tico because
tico loves the ocean
that is the only way we're going to let
our kids go to the ocean by themselves
is after they take a six-week lifeguard
training
you take it buddy go to the beach by
yourself if you don't take it i'm not
letting you go by yourself
i thought it was a brilliant way of
having your kids independently go to the
beach by them so without you being there
oh thanks yeah and
luckily we live a place where you can do
that in the training's phenomenal and
then ivana i think she's gonna be a
lawyer i mean she is
she's got the skills to be a lawyer
right now so i think i might guide her
down that path
you sure you guys are done oh god yes
yeah
for sure yeah okay well i mean gq
magazine's waiting for the next one
the contract will be on the plate at the
moment you need to have that sex talk
with your son
asap and dilly needs to have that talk
every week of his life buddy that guy's
picking up
waitresses at six years old and he's
naturally doing it which is very
interesting okay let's talk about
the legendary john mcafee that's about
john maxwell have you ever seen his
documentary about it i've seen parts of
it
okay that's a weird dude man yeah i have
more questions in the documentary
eric you've seen his documentary have
you ever seen his have you seen this
documentary or no i want to
i want to watch it i mean i have not
seen it yet no well you may change your
mind after you watch it oh okay
have you watched it any one of you guys
okay so here's what just happened with
john mac we indicted for tax evasion
accused of hiding cryptocurrency
uh yacht from irs antivirus software
pioneer mcafee was indicted
the prominent monday tax division kevin
became outrageous and erratic behavior
from tech entrepreneur the indictment
alleges mcafee millions from promoting
cryptocurrencies consulting work
speaking engagements and selling the
rights to his
life story for a documentary but did not
file tax returns
from 2014 to 2018 authorities also
alleged mcafee concealed assets from the
irs including real estate yada car and
cryptocurrency was indicted on june 15
but the document was unsealed
et cetera et cetera et cetera so mcafee
is facing even more legal trouble on
monday he was sued by the sec for
improperly promoting cryptocurrency
icos thoughts on mcafee is he going to
do time
i mean will he actually step foot in a
jail in prison
this guy i remember following him in
like ink magazine or
with the big business magazines and
they'd all all these profiles on them
how did he get caught he was so good at
being evasive and they caught him in
spain and then they're going to
extradite him here
but what what a classic case of uh you
know
the strings just ran out on this guy
right ended
the chances of him going to jail very
slim
is he what country is he in spain is
that where he is
extradition is is that even happening no
i think it is
by the way the sec filing was 55 pages
long that's how thick
the dossier was on the charges for this
guy
what was your take on him from you you
interviewed a sit down in a two-hour
interview with this guy what was your
take on this
brilliant guy though right so i tell you
i'm i thoroughly
enjoyed my sit down with him but i'm
gonna give you the back story
where was the place i'll tell you
exactly how the backstory was so so i'm
in nashville tennessee doing some
business and i'm meeting with arthur
laffer which
you know from the laffer curve arthur
lafrey was on the bush
uh advisor for on the finance side with
reagan with
he's done stuff with george he's doing
stuff with a lot of different people
okay so
we're in tennessee uh we're at barnes
and noble
and mario is in communication with uh
mcafee's camp
so they call and they say okay great
mcif is ready if you guys want to have a
meeting with them
where at his house okay we don't have
the address we start driving to his
house
we pull up to his house i'm on a call
with tom
i'm in my car mario and luis go inside
to set up okay no joke i'm in my car
i'm talking to tom i'm like i'll be
inside a different town yeah yes it
wasn't you i'm i'm gonna phone this this
is three years ago this is three years
ago so
mario and luis go inside to set up and
all of a sudden mario texts me pat
uh they're not comfortable with you
being in the car like i'll finish the
call you said no no you have to come
inside they just frisked us
i said they just what they said they
just risked us
and our buddy luis wasn't too
comfortable about the situation
so i'm like i'll come inside to see
what's going on so i i go inside they're
all looking at me funny like who the
hell is this guy
like hey fellas how you doing and tatted
up
10 ak-47s on the table right there 10.
this is cuba i'm giving you a low number
i'm giving you for real
tennessee yes okay so we go inside the
guys were like
who are you like hey what's up how you
doing i'm patrick with david you know so
who i said so who are you i'm a former
u.s
army ranger i'm a former navy seal on
their town oh that's great i served at
the hunter first airborne what was your
mos
63 bravo it's a hotel eight specialized
i can go out there and do some stuff
with the
you know some of the trucks that i had a
bunch of fm tvs lm tvs at 1500 myself
what unit were you at three two six
engineers get the [ __ ]
give him a come here man bring out the
good whiskey man we're gonna have some
all of us hey listen we got a couple
girls upstairs you want to go upstairs
okay
he says it's good before the interview i
said no i'm totally fine bro and i'm
like
my mario louis do you guys know i'm
teasing you no i'm good
so we're having this drink there's
literally girls upstairs then all of a
sudden all you hear is
like something is opening okay and you
hear
eight german shepherds just barking all
over run around
loud this is loud we're in the
cul-de-sac
house is on the bottom back is wide open
with a bunch of land
and these dogs are so what's going on
this oh john is here it's okay correct
so we're going john shows up with his uh
girl
and uh he comes in keeps wiping his nose
like
50 times and allergies allergies yeah at
the time it's a very
big allergy season so we sit down to do
the interview he's got a gun right
here okay on him while we're doing the
interview in the middle of the interview
it's about 43 minutes into the interview
i believe
in the middle of the interview uh
somebody knocks on the door this person
knocks on the door i'm just kind of like
i'm not even paying attention to the
interview
i'm just matter of fact if you pull it
up you got to pull it up go to john
magnus interview
in the middle of the interview i'm
sitting there and i'm talking to him
somebody knocks on the door
one of the rangers jumps up to the door
with a gun who goes there
who goes there in the middle of the
interview crap
i haven't told you the story oh okay
type in john maxwell i can't believe he
agreed to do an interview
okay so go right there click on that and
uh
uh uh just
mute the audio until i can find the
location uh keep going keep going slowly
and okay
keep going keep going keep going keep
going keep going
right there okay well oh that's going on
keep going keep going keep going keep
going keep going keep going keep going
keep going
it should come up any minute now when a
guy walks if you go a little so you guys
got to see
that straight vodka he's drinking yeah
it's straight vodka is drinking by the
way all of a sudden
i want to really find this because you
have to see the reaction that's what was
crazy about it
my camera guy was so worried
he thought it's over he thought there's
gonna be a shooting keep going a little
faster to see if anything comes up
he right there okay 43 minutes i don't
remember that but 43 minutes okay
watch this okay pause it go back five
seconds
let's hear what's going on um watch this
to um to ecuador from hong kong the last
kind of look at the gun i'd go through
with russia you've got
50 different options or even direct
flights from hong kong to ecuador why
the heck
is he going through um russia
holy crap so um
so i you know it's hard for me
to say is it good
but the point is this so but you know
these are some of the stories people
tell me like oh whatever it's being
exaggerated that's exactly what happened
roll the table
isn't it great when you have a story
like that you can say let me show you
right you got the video
you know i have a story like that do you
remember calvin ayer
he was the founder of bowdog.com the
online gambling site he was on the cover
of the forbes billionaire issue yeah
probably about 12 years ago just an
eccentric crazy guy i used to own this
magazine
called post and it was a great magazine
it was a luxury lifestyle magazine in
sports magazine so
we just went into athletes homes and
never showed them in uniform and
ballers man it was just a cool magazine
he loved it he was living in costa rica
and vietnam and vancouver but he loved
the magazine because we sent it to him
so he flew to phoenix twice to go to a
couple of our parties
right just to come he flew to phoenix
from costa rica and then
he taught me how to the only time i've
ever played poker in my life one time he
taught me how to play texas hold him and
i kind of learned for 15 minutes but
that was it i was horrible at it
then he invites me to costa rica and i
go out there and we're going to do this
photo shoot with him
and we show up and and you know we're
going man it would be cool we did
something in the bathtub oh hang on he
makes a call he has five chicks over
there in a second
in the bathtub with a rubber ducky and
then he he shows up at the door he opens
up the door he had a post magazine
t-shirt on
and with a glass of vodka at nine in the
morning and then you look around and he
had
he lived on a calder or on a residential
street but he owned two houses each on
each side just for security
he had a bulletproof hummer you know the
whole thing just like that and i'm going
to myself
this is a tuesday night for this guy
this is totally normal
this is an average day for this guy how
do you keep up that pace
yeah so some of the by the way here
here's a crazy story about john mcclure
so this interview is happening we have a
good time
we leave we're having all this
conversation together we post the video
and uh there's a couple comments he made
about the uh
price of cryptocurrency he said it's
going to go up to 48 000
in a different interview anyways long
story short
one of the short clips gets five six
million views in the span of like a
couple days when we post on facebook
okay
mcafee is got probably some of the most
loyal followers in the crypto world that
people need to know this he has
a following in the crypto world like no
other
they adore this guy they love this guy
at the same time he has a lot of haters
in the cryptocurrency world
that can't stand it because some claim
that he tells people don't sell crypto
but he sells us crypto
and then it goes down it's so easy to do
marketing
it's so easy to do that with crypto
right on the back end
so you know in his documentary there's a
lot of weird stories one of the stories
was
you know uh he had all these dogs in the
back
and his dogs were playing his next-door
neighbor who sold his company apparently
and he retired and he bought a house
right next to him in the caribbean i
think it's in the caribbean
he returns like listen john i didn't
come here to have a dog bark in a
backyard non-stop
i made all my money to go to an island
and retire so i can do whatever i want
to do
and you're next to me every day i have
to hear about dogs barking
he says i can do whatever i want to do
it's my property mcafee says this
apparently
allegedly long story short the owner of
this house gets pissed off
he puts a poison in a meat throws it
over
mcafee's dog eats it mcafee comes back
with his dog
dead and they find that he ate poison
and then he finds that this guy did it
he hires somebody go take him out so he
gets killed the neighbor gets killed no
yes so this is the guy so this
is the guy you're talking about anyways
so that's one of the part of stories who
he marries in a documentary says who'd
you marry says this is my wife
she says he said he says why'd you marry
her she gives the best
[ __ ] i've ever had in my life this is
what he says
in the documentary says that's why i
married her i just want you to know this
that's marriage material for him boom
this is this is why i say you may not
enjoy the documentary okay
so you're talking about a guy like this
john mcafee it's where he's at right
so what's this again what's going to
happen to him if john mack if social
media was around when john mcafee was
first coming up and he sold mcafee
he would have probably had 50 million
followers he's one of the original
playboys all these guys that wanted to
be playboys
they followed a lot of his steps of what
he did he was one of the original
playboys
on what he did so what's going to happen
to him i think when you're playing with
fire and you need a lot of attention and
you're
no longer getting the kind of attention
you did at one point you're it's
your time is going to come it's not like
you can't do this forever
and when it comes it's not pretty it is
not going to be pretty because
rumor has it in the streets he's running
out of money yeah and when you're
running
out of money you do desperate things
when you start doing desperate things
you eventually get caught
how old do you think he is now i'm gonna
put him in his early 60s oh
i don't know his age i'm going to put
him in the early 60s he looks like a
loose cannon like 7500
what do you think john mcafee tells his
kids when he's having that sex talk with
them
i bet that's uh mary the girl with the
blessed
yeah what i do is i look for the woman
who has no teeth that's what i do and i
marry her that's john mcafee you know
what i'm glad i'm glad he got arrested
after hearing all these stories i hope
he goes to jail
yeah karma man it caught up with him
even in the comments right now we have
people being like he's the man he's epic
yeah
i'm telling you like he's a scumbag he's
the worst that's exactly what should i
tell you
exactly literally polarizing exactly who
he is but guys leave a comment what you
think about this guy john mcafee
epic or the worst what you have to
realize is he
is who he is he's telling there's
nothing about him that he hides though
all authentic that's the part meaning
at least the the benefit about a guy
like this is he's telling you this is
who i am yeah he's not
making stuff up to make himself look
good he just said this is who i am love
me or hate me it is
exactly where were the threats coming
from where he had to have that type of
firepower backing him up did he have
legit death threats or was that just
part of his persona let me put it to you
this way he said
he said i don't use regular phones he
says i have the kind of a phone right
now that i would never use
i can't get any information i want out
of your phone the guy was
you know there's a level of paranoia you
know only the paranoid survive
but there's also the level where you
skip it you can get close to
schizophrenia like you start
imagining like the world is after you
and all this other stuff i mean if you
got that kind of worry about people
coming after you're not living a good
life
it's a very difficult life to live i
mean you get a knock on the door and all
of a sudden you're
you're busting out your guns yeah
exactly it's the craziest thing right
there
i gotta give you credit you've got guns
all around you you've got a drunk
psychopath with a gun on a lot them
wheels
pat didn't flinch knock on the door that
will not be revealed but one day
some people would reveal it it's just
some parts of it so thumbs up thumbs
down for your take on this guy
about what just overall like look you
can't here's the reality of it
who likes paying taxes who who who has
ever said i love paying taxes trump
no one yep 750 dollars is what it is i
i got crush paying taxes but the one
thing you can't do it's this it's crazy
i read an article one time there was a
company that was going around saying
you know there's no law written that you
have to pay taxes
and they were campaigning around this
until eventually the guy got caught and
he had to pay taxes so
i i get the rebellious side of i don't
have to pay any taxes
but you're living in a country where you
got to pay taxes if you avoid that
there's a price to be paid and you got
to pay the price so
let's talk about trump let's go let's go
into trump here brother if you're
watching this if you're enjoying this
press the thumbs up we got a big
announcement to make to here
shortly which we are very very excited
about
and uh uh uh you know outside of that uh
if you
haven't subscribed to the channel press
that sub button and press that
notification button so every time we go
live
uh the the podcast appears on your phone
so let's talk about trump
so trump gets coveted you know and he
comes out
on the date was what was the day
thursday night so the first october
first
at 11 54. kaify can pull up his tweet
he comes up at 11 54 11 54 p.m look at
that
at 11 54 he comes out and says tonight
first lady and i tested positive for
covert 19.
first lady and i tested positive cover
19 we will begin our quarantine and
recovery process immediately kai i think
you pressed your mic and i hear
additional noise
turn it off oh yeah so and i test
deposit for covet 19 we will begin our
quarantine and recovery process
immediately we will get through this
together
okay fyi that is the most liked tweet
he's ever posted in his career just so
you guys know
there's never been a tweet that got more
likes than this tweet
okay then he goes to the next video okay
click on the next video he posts this
video we don't have to watch the whole
thing he's kind of talking about his
experience
we're getting great reports from the
doctor his boss is an incredible host
look at the views
26.5 million likes
go to the next one uh the next video
he posts here this is october 3rd the
day before
if you look at it no tie on can you
pause the audio kai
no tie on you know just giving a message
his hair is not fixed you can tell he's
not in the best place there 37.7 million
views go to the next one
here's another one update he gives
october 2nd so we just watch it in
chronological order but backwards
because guys from norway but we went
from the fourth to the second
this is the first one he did after
tweeting it out it got 33.2 million
views so let's do the math
so he first tweets it out 1.8 million
likes
33.2 million views 39 million views
27 million views of him saying i'm
getting through this
right and then he comes out and he
starts
leaving walter reed and he's going out
there in the public
and on both sides your stuff on cnn
people on cnn coming out saying i'm
we're not surprised this happened pelosi
we're always praying for the president
but we're not surprised it happened a
lot of people are not surprised by it
happened i'm not surprised by it
happened
a former obama staffer sent out a tweet
i don't think caillou have that but i'll
read it because i have it here on my
phone
a former obama staffer tweeted out and
said
it's against it's been against my moral
identity to tweet this for the past four
years
but i hope he dies zara raheem if you
want to pull that up they can kind of
see the tweet
it was taking that immediately after he
posted it she posted it
then steve cox by i hope they both die
originally he says i hope they both die
you know he originally was meaning trump
and melania then he retweeted steve cox
says i was talking about trump and bite
not melania she seems nice you quoted me
out of context shame
okay now all this stuff is happening uh
i got more stuff i can talk about this
but i'm gonna turn it over to you
what are your thoughts about what's
going on with trump having coveted i
like how cox says
shame on you when you text something
like that okay anyway um
well let's go back to the announcement
uh and the reason i think that he got
all those likes is
literally i think you can say this in
all the four years he's been president
that's the first time he ever seemed
human
it humanized him that he can actually
contract a disease be a little bit
humble
be a little bit vulnerable and i think
that resonated with a lot of people
um that were moved by that thing but
then
reality sets in a couple days later and
he's a fighter
and he's in an election battle right now
and it's do or die
and i think the last thing he wants to
do is show weakness
so i think it probably scared him right
away especially with the fact that his
wife had it and then he's thinking about
all the
you know he's still a human he's
thinking about all the people he was
around and he's probably thinking to
himself man
a lot of people probably do have the
potential of catching this and it is
this is not going to look good this is
not a great look
for him at all but then i it didn't take
long i mean by the weekend he was back
in fighter mode
and you know and then the drive-by that
he did at the hospital on sunday
and now he's back in the white house and
he's recovering there and he plans on
going out campaigning again so
you know i think the most important
thing is i think it shows to people that
you can contract this at a later age
and hopefully be okay i mean the whole
stigma around this thing is if you get
it you're going to die
i mean every time you hear about in the
nfl we got to shut these games down no
college
everything is kind of an overreaction a
little bit i mean we've had to be
careful and safe and everything but
it's proven that you know college kids
aren't dying just dropping dead by
playing college
football and contracting covet so um i i
ultimately personally think it's going
to help him i think it it it's it's a
an advantage for him to have gone
through this survived it and and have
the last four weeks with this in his
background
i didn't even know he had kova i just
this is me first time hearing about it
today
um a lot to unpack here i
let's just talk about a 72 year old man
surviving why you're doing why are you
doing this i'm just curious folks if
you're watching this
does this help him does this hurt him
why don't you say yes or no say yes
because of this
no because of that that that go ahead
adam yes or no
so he's not just any average 72
74 74. he's not just the uh some average
74 year old who contracted covet
freaking president united states they're
they're not going to let this guy
die like they're going to give him every
single treatment every single steroid
every single
drug to make sure that he lives and
survives straight up so
whether it's not some just 75 year old
dude in iowa that contracted a good luck
buddy
like it's the freaking president they're
not they're going to give him everything
he needs
what i think you know i did a poll on
on my instagram um has this helper heard
him sixty percent of people said that
this
helps him 40 obviously i think it's hurt
i don't you know
i don't know how this helps him per se i
mean getting coveted i don't think is a
good thing i mean at the end of the day
do you want covet or do you knock him on
covet i'll go with the the not covet
option thanks
but let's just talk about who around his
inner circle
got covet right his wife so
uh hope hicks that was the big news i
think earlier that friday
kaylee mcinerney the white house press
secretary yes several
uh u.s senators tom tillis ron johnson
uh governor
chris christie kovid not a healthy guy
by the way good luck with him
kellyanne conway his homegirl uh bill
stephen
trump campaign manager ron mcdaniel rnc
chairwoman
mike lee u.s senator uh nick luna
assistant to the president his
closest inner circle including his wife
and secretary
press secretary al kovet
this might humanize these people but it
also shows holy crap
if covid can seep its way into the
highest office in the land
and everyone surrounding him this is
pretty serious stuff right here
okay i don't like anyone who wished the
president death
you got to reassess where you're coming
from okay i don't care if you're on the
left
you're on the right like i if i if i
could go back and i thought
and i and i liked obama i wasn't like a
huge you know nutty obama fan but i
thought he was a good president i
thought he was a good person
if there were people on the right
wishing obama
death which i'm sure some people were i
would tell that person dude what's wrong
with you what the hell's wrong with you
same thing goes for trump
if there's people out there on the left
who are wishing for
death for the president united states
like dude what are you doing
like relax it's not that serious someone
texted me the other day
or messaged me um how could because i
because i was when i did the story
whether you you know
think it's helpful or hurts and i was
basically kind of just playing in the
middle
what do you think what do you think they
message me how could you possibly
even consider voting for hitler junior
i was like i'm like what are you talking
about donald trump is hitler junior i go
listen
how because my sister is actually a
trump fan my sister
you know doesn't know what she's doing
politically just in general nothing like
but
like she i want to know who your mom is
working for my mom would not vote for
trump
not whatsoever but if you're like she
would consider him
yes of course my grandmother voted for
trump the first time around now
she's in michigan now no chance she
would vote for trump so i have family
members that can go left or right
but i tell this person to text me about
the hitler junior i go be careful with
the [ __ ] words you're using
you're calling the president of the
united states whether you hate him or
love him
hitler jr do you know how absurd you
sound you know
absolutely absurd you sound so what i
think this country
needs whether you're on the left or the
right it's just a little respect for the
other side of the aisle
i'm not a trump fan that's no secret
yeah but i respect the 40
of our country that does respect trump
that does passionately love trump so
i just try to think if the other shoes
on the other foot and obama or clinton
or whoever
was contracted coveted whatever you
think of them you don't wish
death upon somebody yeah okay so get it
together people so that's where you're
at and by the way your grandma
who switched from trump to now biden i
don't know if you know or not
she has a grandson that's thinking about
switching from
hillary to trump i don't know if you
know that no no no different grounds
different group he's thinking we still
got our bet
he's still he's uh he's yeah i told you
i told you yesterday what i would do
with that
my position hasn't changed uh although i
do think this is a big curveball and it
can go
many different directions and a couple
things on what i mean many different
directions by the way if you can put the
washington post story up and
what chris evans from hollywood said
here's the washington post tweet
this post has been removed the post has
removed a tweet picture below which was
written thursday and released through an
automated program because the subsequent
news of president trump infection
rendered it tasteless opinion imagine
what it would look like to never have to
think about trump again
this is from washington post so they
took responsibility didn't take
responsibility it's kind of like well
at least they did it but it's automated
we didn't do it we would never say
something like it's more like an
automated
i don't know a lot of automated titles
that create things like this this is an
opinion which means you
somebody came up with a title here's
what chris evans just tweeted out
a couple days ago 19 hours ago where
trump first let me read
trump's tweet on what okay perfect it
says i will be leaving the great walter
reed medical center today at 6 30pm
feeling very good
really good don't be afraid to covet
don't let it dominate your life we have
developed under trump administration
some really great
great drugs and knowledge i feel better
than i did 20 years ago okay
so go back and then chris evans this is
aka captain america by the way you guys
got to write when captain america says
stuff you got to listen to him
he said don't be afraid of covet huh
you've been under around the uh
you've been under around round-the-clock
care by the best doctors using the best
drugs do you really think everyone has
access to that yes chris evans does i
totally agree
sadly i'm sure you're aware of that
disparity
you just don't care the reckless this is
reckless to shocking degree
even for you okay are you saying you
agree with that i
actually 100 percent agree with chris
which part
that he has the best care in the world
it's so easy for donald trump to say
don't be worried about kovid
meanwhile we have 200 000 americans that
have died and a million people say
worrying
guys this is okay you can't play
those cards that you're playing here you
this is a 74 year old man
that got coveted okay let me ask you a
question does herman came have access to
the same drugs that he has
no yes he's a no the moment you're
officially qualified
rich you have access to same drugs that
money
does he have access to good drugs sure
does he have access to the same
care as the president
let me ask you a question why is oj
simpson free today
because borah had interviewed it was a
great interview
why is why is o.j simpson free today
because what's he doing
why does he have great lawyers yeah he
had that money oh oh oh so because he
has money so
how about the criticism of a lot of
famous people that have gotten away with
you don't think that
wealthy people have died from covid what
are you saying what i'm trying to tell
you is
if he was gonna die from covid whether
you give him medicine or not if the body
was weak he's gonna die
so you can't take you can't take one
position and just kind of play
i stay in the middle with this no no i
don't go chris evans but i also don't go
the other side
i'm in the middle with this okay he's
made let's just say he makes it through
this
great say he makes it through this okay
let me tell you what's about to happen
here here's a couple things that's about
to happen
on one end when it comes down to
marketing
you have to know who's a better marketer
period
there is no question trump's the better
marketer than biden
number obviously number one hope hicks
semi-genius i've spoken to a few times
before we were trying to do an interview
four years ago
and she is at 23 24 years old she spoke
like she's 45 years old
kellyanne conway she's a genius to put
the words together she's a wordsmith if
you don't think she is you're the full
because
if you ever watch her interviews she may
have helped the last election save trump
because here's a woman
without a doubt without a doubt she
needs to work on her own household
and by the way they posted a picture
yesterday she actually came out positive
and she's with her daughter right now
spending time which is good to see them
together with the family
kelly on conway but you go through all
of even obama against mccain who had a
better marketing team
obama yeah yeah sanders against biden
who had a better marketing team
sanders sanders had a better marketing
team trump is going to know how to use
this
they have to know that and the one part
is now imagine in the next debate
the topic of covet 19 comes up trump
says
biden you've never had it before you
don't know what it feels like i do
believe you can't talk from experience i
have experience let me teach you
the world is going to say ah damn it
if he uses it to say i know what it is
to have covet i have personal experience
biden you don't you can't speak on this
topic
i can speak on it from experience that
gives him an edge and he's going to know
how to use that in his advantage
advantage
period that's one part that's going to
be taking place next
1.8 million people click and like on his
tweet
you know 39 million views 33 million
views 27 28 29 million views
people have sympathy for him right now
this is the time when people have
sympathy
if there's ever that you don't want your
opponent to get sympathy votes it's
today
sympathy votes are very weird votes
because sympathy votes is not about
whether you like the other guy or not
sympathy votes are oh man i just feel
bad even if you're right people will go
to the sympathy side say your husband
and wife argue say their husband is
right
wife is crying you will generally say
what what dude come on bro mary i'm so
sorry will you you understand what i'm
saying
sympathy vote sympathy votes are
powerful votes and they know how to use
sympathy votes now on the complete
opposite side
what the left is going to do is what do
you want somebody
leading a nation this reckless do you
want somebody
that is this reckless that has access to
the button do you want somebody that has
no control
of decision making and you know he
doesn't listen to anybody and
he's going out there and driving around
in this limo and god knows who else is
getting covered and
look how many people around him are
getting it he doesn't care he doesn't
wear the mask all this other stuff right
um we're about to find out in the next
four weeks
if this is going to end up helping this
guy out or not but i think
from a marketing standpoint it's going
to help him out joe biden's listening to
you right now and he's going to go try
to contract it today yeah he wants it he
wants that sympathy
well i tell you one thing though let me
give you the other crazy thing let me
give you the other crazy thing
so i'm having to talk with a couple of
my guys and
so interesting so one of the guys i know
he he not in our company in a different
company he has some
issues in his marriage okay
and he says uh dude let me just say what
i got to tell my company so what's that
i just really don't want to go to an
event that they're having i'm going to
tell my boss that i got covered so what
do you mean
okay i'm just going to tell him you're
serious he says yes
he said dude you're going to tell me you
got a copy said you know you got to show
if you got it he says yeah i know but
i'm not
w-2 okay so i'm going to say i've
coveted i said he can still ask him he
can still fire you says yeah i know they
can slow firemen so you're taking a risk
i'm taking that risk it's okay
so anyways he takes that position guess
what happens a week later
he got covered no no you're fine he
didn't he said that because he didn't
want to go with his wife
he's no no
so he just said i got colbert okay um
i think there is a very big power play
if biden in the next week comes out
saying there's covet because he doesn't
have to debate
there's you think there's a power play
with him saying he got kovid yeah i dude
no chance but wait a minute i'm just
look i'm just
you're throwing stuff against the wall
i'm not throwing stuff against the wall
you're stipulating you're saying and i'm
giving back you
you commented it and i'm coming back to
what you said i didn't come up with the
idea you said it yourself some
what did i say we're talking about this
whole thing about what could possibly
happen
trump said living in some bubble of
emotion right now
i think tom said that what if he comes
back and bites yes kobe gotcha
so if he says that if he comes out with
it
it's also a strategic move not
necessarily if he goes intentionally
gets it
if they say he has symptoms we're
worried we don't want to we want to
cancel debate because it's the
responsible thing to do
then you got the people on one side that
are voting for the quality they value
the most
responsibility biden seems so
responsible he cares about the people
around them
then the other side is people like tom
that they're going to say freaking trump
is not afraid even four days after
heaven he's going out they're still
getting the job done he's not showing
any that's the kind of a leader i want
we're going to see which one of those to
america has more up yeah
well what do we always talk about
there's 12 percent of this country that
10. is it 10 42 40 44
okay so just a back up 42 of the country
is going to vote for trump
no matter what 42 42 not 49 not 32
people out there listening 44 42. 44
are going to vote for biden straight up
that's the number yes so 40 so that so
that's
that's 86 yes so now we have
14 remaining four percent are going to
maybe vote for
joe jorgensen or the libertarian or the
green party so we're talking 10 percent
of the country is that the number
10 of the country's innovation so that's
that's what's going to move the needle
the 10
of this country in ohio and pennsylvania
bless you covet
um yeah in the states pennsylvania
wisconsin
uh michigan florida north carolina
arizona all these swing states that's
really who matters
i don't really care if you're in new
york california there's certain states
that don't matter
the ten percent of those in those states
they're going to determine this election
so they're going to have to determine
whether they think you know go back to
capitals
right go to captain america's tweet
here's the thing that really annoys me
about that comment um
you know what what's so wrong with
saying don't be afraid
why do you have to live your life in
fear i mean it's okay to respect the
fact that kovitt is out there
but i don't want to be afraid of it i
mean there are people
people are just wired so different i
know people right now that still won't
let their kids go hang out won't let
them leave the house basically yeah and
i'm going
you know at some point you got to get
out from underneath the rock here
i mean life is a series of risks that
you take yeah you know i i think i got
coveted i really do i went to new york
in february
in february i was at jfk airport i was
at times square
at a hotel i was at 30 rock i mean i was
in new york in the minute i came back
and i was sick
i was really sick i mean down for a week
but then i was back so i thought i had
it
but i mean my god i mean why can't we
let
some people be okay with not living
their life in constant fear
i think it's inspiring that someone can
get it and come back from it you know we
have this neighbor
this is funny we were going for a walk
one day and this lady she was by her
house she was sitting outside
and she was just super friendly and and
shawna just goes to her hey how's it
going oh good good good you know
and i saw we had she had a bottle of
wine out there it was like 10 10 30 in
the morning on a on a on a
sunday how old is she she was like 80
she was 80 and she was super spunky
and she was oh hey how you doing how you
feeling oh i'm feeling just fine you
know i think it's that viking blood in
me that's keeping me alive i go oh yeah
why is that well i'm from minnesota and
you know i'm just hearty you know well
my husband died two weeks ago so her
husband was 84
contracted covid died she caught it it
lived
here's the funniest thing about the
story though
they cremated him and his favorite car
was his uh
sitting in the garage so they just put
him in an urn and he's sitting on
the driver's seat of his car inside the
garage
but she is i mean it was unbelievable
how she is just like
her husband literally died two weeks ago
from kobe but she survived
at the age of 84 and and he's sitting
there in the garage
in a jar on the driver's seat so
drinking wine i mean two weeks left look
she wasn't
you know hiding or you know was she
happily married or was she like kind of
clyde
yeah i don't know i'm not sure
minnesota yeah she was originally from
minnesota so minnesota i think
it is kind of the middle east though so
you know of us so
um you know what'd be funny to make this
year to say don't be afraid
is for trump's camp to go find a clip
of captain america saying don't be
afraid in one of the movies and putting
your idea the man
who said don't be afraid is afraid you
know so but but you know these guys here
uh that they're going back and forth to
taking shots at each other i think the
bigger question can i ask
is why is the the mask wearing and kovid
so politicized right like why is it
so politicized like okay
on that side on every side yeah why are
you like
on the left you're anti-american you're
anti um
science if you don't wear a mask but if
you're on the right and you
and you and you people are wearing masks
uh you're taking away my liberty like
why is it so political
like it's not the cope is just not just
happening in america it's happening all
around the world right
in mexico it's horrible in india it's
horrible in brazil it's horrible there's
certain
europe is going on lockdown round two
why is it so politicized in america why
is it so
you are a master you must be a democrat
you don't wear a mask you must be a
republican like why is it
like just as someone who lean you know
is center left
you think i like wearing a mask you
think i want to go out on saturday night
wear a freaking mask you think this is
cool for me
or gucci message guys no that's our boy
ricky aguilar
but why is it so politicized so like
i i took a picture the other day of me
not wearing a mask i got
hate from liberal friends of mine how do
you
how dare you not wear a mask i'm like
bruh by myself
wherever i was i don't even know i was
just outside wherever i was
just just normal yeah how do you not
wear a mask
you're setting a bad precedent people on
the right go get them buddy you show
these people you don't need a mask
why is it so politicized trump says he's
going to start campaigning again i mean
he said this is not going to slow him
down
doesn't he have to do 14 days of
quarantine
how do you get out of it trump don't
give a [ __ ] man he's going to co he's
going to
he's going to he's going to campaign
covet or no covet
part of that that's so attractive to an
audience but there's also a part of that
that's
very unattractive to an audience you
know uh he's the john mcafee of politics
people either love him or hate him
you know i wouldn't go that far no i
wouldn't go there i think so no
no come on you don't think people's what
was incorrect about what i said what do
you mean he's a john mcafee of politics
i mean what kind of things
meaning you either love him or hate him
if it's that category that's what i'm
saying
you know it's uh you know if it's that
part would it be fair to say that
trump supporters love this man or hate
him
no no no trump supporters absolutely
love this man i don't i don't i don't
know if all of them do
but for the most part no i think i i
think there's a group that just simply
vote because they're scared of what's
going on on the complete opposite side
i'm being that serious with you and
they're like like i have a
a a very close run you guys know the
name i'm not going to say this name on
tv because
this person wouldn't want people to know
which person which way this person
they cannot stand trump
at all but they're going to vote for
trump simply because
they have no desire to see what the
other direction is going if you're
asking about trump's true believers yeah
they are crazy about him
crazy brothers are true believers i'm
talking about the josh's of the world
the whoever's of the world they know he
can do it and it's not no wrong
tom might even be in that camp i'm not
so sure people that like
bullying bullies yeah it's people don't
like bullying bullies look you watch
hunger games what's hunger games all
about
it's the government controlling people
you read any you
robin hood is about what the government
taxing more of its citizens it's not
robin hood doesn't go and take money
from the rich people and give it to poor
robin hood ghost takes money from the
government and gives it to
the people that's what statesmen
essentially do to say
minimize and lower the taxes a little
bit why are you taking so much money
from everyday workers
so you this is not about this is not
about comparing it at that level but
uh i get your point on what you're
making by the way just so you know a lot
of people here are saying the following
a lot of people are giving you a lot of
love adam just so you know a lot of
people are saying adam is growing on me
i appreciate adam being sentimental and
not lacking the fact that the left is
going after trump
so you got a lot of uh uh soyboy
hashtags on fire today like so we're
gonna hashtags on fire today
but i try not to read the comments but
then but some people said it's not gonna
help them
some people are saying it is gonna help
them uh i would say
70 30 saying help to not help um
you know and and people got some
commentary about uh
uh about uh you know what i will say
about our audience
is that they we obviously have a a i
would say in my opinion a
70 30 pro republican is an entrepreneur
channel
okay the audience is business people and
just so you guys understand
even though i don't necessarily agree
with trump
don't think that i'm not a capitalist
don't think that i don't respect
your opinions so uh much love for all
you guys out there
cassandra aguilar adam is growing on me
jonathan burgess
we love you adam yeah
go ahead you know it's on the table that
they do this next debate via zoom so
it'll be interesting to see if biden
tries to just
use this to get out of the next update
that's what i'm expecting next
you know what's the fallout you know
what's going to happen the next couple
days because
can we talk about the biden debate
we because we don't think we brought it
brought that up i don't know if we have
we i don't know i think i got dementia i
don't know
where we live but what
his expectations drink spice or
something what is it roofies
shout out to jarrah she put something in
that drink
for you but biden you know his
expectations were so
low like i thought he was gonna come out
there like on a skeleton
and like just you know um pinocchio that
thing out there
um and he actually seemed cognitive
which means which means the following
which means
may not be a bad idea to have a part two
so if the biden camp thinks
truly what you think which is he did
better than expected
guess what if you're so confident you
should have a part two and a part i
think they
100 should have another debate i hope
you're right i don't
i hope he doesn't wait for trump to say
i know what it's like to have coveted i
can't wait for that line to be dropped
right but i think i think it'll make
congratulations bro this is when science
and karma meet
trump gets caught up that was a good
line by you know who said science
has tonight snl with jim carrey yeah
shout out to jim carrey's impersonation
of biden and
you know alec baldwin i think does a
does a great job uh doing his uh
trump thing i didn't have a town hall
last night on nbc in miami
right across the street from my career
unbiased by the way
just like that trump one when they were
attacking him not
um he says he regrets calling trump a
clown
he says he wished he would have said it
was clownish behavior
so he's back building on that one a
little bit i got it i got to make a
comment dignified
here we go this is the problem with
people and you know what i call
you know they're they're twitter tough
i'm not even going to read the name
soyboy is a communist antifa blm
like dude what are you talking about
just because i don't agree with you on
loving
trump something you're not telling us
yeah i'm a i'm a
communist antifa blm is it because i'm
not a fan of trump
get it together background check on adam
or no we gotta we gotta get our cia
people to follow up on this
marxist communist uh
you know melania didn't even have
freaking enough listen hold up pull up
the melania recording that was uh
shared with one of her former friends by
the way folks if you have friends like
this you don't need enemies
this is a friend who is sharing this
phone call the main thing
if you haven't seen this already we can
listen to it together and have a
reaction
i just want you to see at the end when
anderson cooper is speaking for 15
minutes
of his reaction to this i want you to
see the reaction of her face
like just see her face at the end that's
what i want you to focus on
but first if you haven't heard it play
it let's hear it together this is july
28th
i'm the same like him i support him i
don't say enough i don't do enough
where i am
christmas stuff and decoration but i
need to do it right yeah but
100 you have no choice and okay and then
i do it and i say that i'm working on
christmas
and planning for the christmas and they
said oh what about the children that
they were separated
give me a break
where they were saying anything when
obama did that i know
i cannot go i i was trying
to get the kid reunited with the mom i
i didn't have a chance needs to go
through the process and through the law
but here's my thing hear what you just
said but instead of that
if you just your messaging
you you were so loved you heard the
story
we put it out
they would not do the story because
no they are not they would not do the
story because they are they are
they are again look what she says
uh you know i certainly doesn't jive
with you know the fox
whole idea i mean from talking to war on
christmas um
it's funny that she would be leading
that that um but you see that certainly
it it's one of those traditional roles
and
trying to hold it together i don't know
it's fascinating her talk like that
yeah pause it her reaction is because
she can't believe she betrayed her like
that and now she's on tv talking about
it she looks completely embarrassed and
ashamed
okay and here's the other thing they
completely misread that melania wasn't
trivializing christmas she was saying
most americans don't really care that
i'm hanging decorations but yet she has
to act like it's a big deal
that's what she was talking about but i
loved anderson cooper's reaction he was
just
failure to compute he was just trying to
find something negative to say about her
in that moment and that's all he could
pull out
all i got to say is i'm in favor of
legal immigration
for anyone and everyone who looks like
melania trump 100 percent
let him in the country you'd like
popcorn anything
the one the best thing that trump has
going for him and i'm not even being
facetious right now the best thing
adam is that melania and trump and
ivanka trump
are certified female studs like they
maybe listen to anything she said
like did she talk about the yankees
having a shot at winning
what did she say actually tell us what
she said what was she talking about she
was talking about collecting
christmas and stories and getting and
getting and getting uh
the the the border and the moms and the
connected with the kids
she's just so freaking gorgeous that you
know she could say whatever the hell she
wants to say
like i don't know same with ivanka trump
these like
that's the best thing that trump has
going on he's got good-looking wife
good-looking daughter
the [ __ ] show around him is ridiculous
but he he
so let me get this straight taxes are
not going to convert you no policies are
not going to convince you to convert you
but how beautiful melania is she could
conversely vote for trump
well she said says a lot about your
standards that's where i'm at now that's
where i'm at straight up that is that
that's really what
that's the one thing i'll tell you about
trump i'm being honest here guys
if you're out there in the crowd right
now and you're not like
you know and everyone knows i'm true
everyone knows this is true you take a
look
you take a look at i'll tell you one
thing you take a look at ivanka trump
and then you take a look at uh not to
get all
weird here you take a look at pete
butterjudge and his uh potential husband
walking down are you kidding me
give me ivanka try give me uh melania
trump any day of the week
okay i'm just saying you look at uh
bernie sanders wife whatever that
[ __ ] is
and then you and then you look at ivanka
trump come on
they got a good-looking situation going
on over here that's all i'm saying
people could be like this or that or
this or that yeah you know it's true
they're gorgeous what are you gonna say
i don't know what the hell she was
talking about they're hanging the
christmas
i don't know i don't know they like me i
don't care what she's saying just
gorgeous and there it is
there it is i said it there it
i see people is want me to say that for
you you say she is the hottest first
lady ever
ever for sure not even close
not even close with jackie o maybe but
not so much i don't know
marilyn monroe was she considered a
first night you see calvin
not bad just kidding abraham lincoln's
wife
uh so would you disagree that she's the
hottest first wife i mean
first lady i wouldn't disagree i mean
how could you she's a freaking
supermodel and i love the way how uh
how she is okay i'll tell you what
whenever trump leaves office whether
it's in four weeks or in four years
nicholas mattis asked adam yeah from
here until the election what would trump
have to do to win your vote outside of
marrying
hooking me up with the chick that looks
like melania done we got it sister
you hooked me up melania's sister i take
care of you um
are we gonna talk about borah part two
is that coming up gonna make a point
cause i will say this whether trump
leaves office in four weeks or in four
years
when she writes a book yeah number one
bestseller
dave comes out straight up yeah she's
got some secrets she's got some stories
she's smarter than you think she is
she's got worse i spent the whole day
with her yeah she was it was impressive
you spent the day with her tell me about
the day with her i interviewed her for a
magazine and we've been
um this whole time you've been holding
out stories you're telling stories about
weirdos in costa rica that's where this
story
adam's here what did you do it was the
top floor of their hotel on in central
park okay you know amazing view
how long ago was this this was probably
maybe this is pre-president yeah this
was like
you know when apprentice was dying down
but i mean i was impressed i really was
she was super cool she was professional
she was cordial um she was personable
and i was really impressed i mean
you go in there and you're thinking that
you know maybe you have these
preconceived notions that she doesn't
you know it's just her looks and
everything that got her but man she's an
impressive person
she was very accomplished in russia to
come she's strategic she is a
calculating individual she is not
someone
i mean there's been deals that have been
made i'm sure for her to put up with
what she's had to put up with over the
years i mean
she's a very very brilliant calculating
person and you're right about the book i
think it'd be an amazing read no
question
straight up she knows that trump has
cheated on her she has to know that
right
she's not a dummy buddy okay yeah but
she's sticking by her man
there you go i think it's a power is one
hell of a drug man
let's talk because she knows what she
signed up for let's talk about what
let's talk about the real issue here
does this do anything
do you look at this and say unfair
towards her do you look at this and say
you know the media is definitely being
biased and they're not you know
the other day did you see the cnn story
that came out the other day first wives
go to cnn first wives
just tap it on google cnn first wives
check this out cnn first lady is in
first
uh first uh ladies first ladies yeah it
was on twitter as well but you're gonna
have to go through 50 tweets
uh go to em first ladies and gentlemen
only
uh uh go to that just see the first
ladies recap
no no the cnn yeah right there go below
it so they just came out with a
documentary
that's the one right there the cnn
special documentary called
first lady so just type in on google
first ladies
first ladies and gentlemen go to images
ladies
then go to images
images there you go uh so
stand tapping cnn next to it maybe let's
see if that'll come up
so they just did a series okay on cnn
that one right there click on it
perfect so who's missing on there wow
the current
michelle's big hillary's big she would
have messy
nancy reagan's the size of michelle's
ear okay
look at that and melania's not on there
a lot of people are not when did this
come out this just came out a couple
days ago that's
unacceptable i mean look at hillary
don't accept this just came out four
days ago yeah i mean even for marketing
purposes because you got to put more
media bias against melania 100 yeah but
but i tell you for me
again this is not scripted right what
melania did
for me couple things happen number one
that woman
who's going to hire her i actually want
you to ask the question so you're about
to interview her and hire her would you
consider hiring her hell no
would you say she's basically leaking
stories she's leaking secrets
she's no no she is leaking a private
phone call with her friend
would you hire somebody like that
obviously not okay so she probably got
paid for doing this
sharing this she lost her credibility
how much you got paid probably 20 grand
it's not even that much
the point i'm trying to make to you is
imagine that's your mom
say that's your mom forget about it it's
your mom it's your wife it's your sister
actually look at it from that standpoint
that is your mom your mom just
leaked somebody's conversation what do
you tell your mom what are you doing
so so imagine you're going to work every
day and that's your mom
so you your mom is that's your mom your
mom is that person
oh my gosh i would never and then i'm
not trusting you because you come from
that lineage that's the kellyanne conway
one of the worst things you could do is
to cut
the person that hired you to be their
alliance to trust you to open up and cry
like this freaking rule number one of
character
if some it might dude my enemies i know
stuff on my enemies that are very very
dark thing i
still won't leak it to people okay i
still won't lick you to people
that's what are you doing with that you
know unbelievable
what are you doing with something like
that that's number one second thing
i felt her pain i sympathize with her
i'm stuck you know what
i can see what she's going through i can
see the fact that she's ousted
no one's probably reaching out no one's
probably talking to her no one's
probably doing anything with her
you know who's contacting her definitely
not george bush's wife because
she doesn't like trump so she's not
calling and saying is there anything we
can help you out with no
because they're part of obama's and
clinton's camp they're on the complete
opposite side
these guys are now so she's alone she's
by herself who is she talking to
that knows her experience i don't think
anybody does but
uh so you know again when i saw this i
was kind of disappointed to see
that a advisor that's a friend of yours
that's going to come out talking like
that for you but i actually think it
helped that melania because the world
saw a different side of melania
yeah i think we're like you know what
damn what was the last comment that she
could do it on fox but she didn't want
to why because she knows that's easy
that's a layup no she knows she doesn't
want to do it on fox because
everyone's going to say of course fox
would do a story like this
she wants that story to be on the cnn or
abc's or cbs or nbc or something like
that
can you imagine no one wants to do a
story on the first lady how many people
would watch it it's a money-making
opportunity still say no to it you know
i was listening to the conversation i
was wondering when did it click for that
woman that
she was going to release this tape like
i felt listening to it
she was setting her up i thought during
that conversation
she was egging her on encouraging her
and already thinking about selling that
thing
much respect to the audience we just
cracked three thousand give a
give a like give a [ __ ] yeah give them
awesome put a thumbs up put a
sub and share it as well let's let's
talk about an issue that's very close to
me
uh and uh my lineage and my family for
some of you that know
or don't know my mother is armenia diana
borussia mom john if you're listening to
this uh
first language i spoke was armenian and
then assyria my dad is assyrian asori
david the house of david betta surviving
surah yami adam netanyahu
also i got a phone call and i was
talking to the
the actor of the new movie coming out on
uh
on uh apple called tehran have you guys
seen this tehran tehran tehran
i watched the whole thing i think the
fifth one's coming out this friday
so the main actor has been sending me
messages
for a couple months on instagram and
i've not been following it the main guy
that's
interrogating everybody whose wife has a
surgery all that's a ghost of purse
so he sent him out i'll get to it i
don't i don't know what he's talking
about i honestly have no clue what he's
talking
about then i watch that tehran comes up
and i'm watching like
wow then i see his name coming says
that's my movie's out have you seen i
said that's you
so what a great job he did acting i was
so impressed he said do you speak farsi
i said you know i can speak 90 i
understand what they're saying
so i speak armenian first language a
syrian second language
uh farsi third language then you have a
german fourth language and then it's
english i took efl five languages
german i can understand if you speak to
me i can't speak it okay i understand it
but i can't speak it so
armenia and azerbaijan full out
war right now hundreds of people have
been killed
um we are officially on the ninth day
that this is taking place if you're
following this
uh protesting's been going on now for
quite some time in glendale there were a
lot of peaceful uh protesting going on
with armenians yesterday
a few days ago armenians went on the 101
freeway on both
sides holding up the armenian flag
saying we got to bring attention to this
event that's taking place in armenia
right now
and uh you know eventually yesterday in
l.a the councilman came out mayor
garcetti sent the video they gave a
statement
all of them were wearing armenian masks
if you haven't seen that cat if you want
to pull it up
uh uh la councilman armenia
mask if you want to put that up uh it
should show up armenia mask
this was just literally yesterday yeah
right there if you go to images
this was yesterday so they gave a talk
and they all had armenia mask to
represent what's taking place
um so what is really going on let's talk
about a little bit of the details of
what's really going on i want to hear
your inputs as well with the
this uh challenge so i had a
conversation
with eric israelian who is the producer
of the movie the promise if you've not
seen the movie the promise you got to go
watch the promise
the promise there this was the last
project that kirkakorian did before he
died he wanted to make sure the story of
the armenian genocide
was told and so he said i don't care how
much money we spent i want to be able to
do this movie
guess who's the leading actor christian
bale he crushes it
if you've not seen it you got to go
watch the promise kai can we put the
link below for people to see the promise
imdb so they can go watch it for
themselves pull up
i talked to i talked to eric yesterday
for a good hour and when i spoke for a
good hour eric's a doctor he's done
great things he's also the producer of
the movie
we had very interesting conversations
together last week on
uh uh sunday i got a call from armenia
with the head of press of nicole
pacinian we had a good 20 30 minute
conversation together i'm
we're trying to schedule time for us to
interview nicole paschina the prime
minister of armenia
but let's talk about a little bit of the
events timeline of what really took
place in 1923
stalin when he was the acting commissar
of nationalities
uh for the decided to make a karabakh
region an autonomous oblast of soviet
azerbaijan okay 1923 that's what stalin
did so meaning
it's the property and under control of
azerbaijan but it's led
by armenians with a community that they
have the current conflict began in 1988
when karabakh armenians demanded that
karabakh be transferred to soviet
azerbaijan
from savida zabra john to soviet armenia
meaning
it was under soviet azerbaijan the
armenians from ghana
says we want to be moved over to soviet
armenia why because as the soviet
union weakened armenia population did
not want to remain within the azerbaijan
and declared independence in 1991.
obviously there was guerrilla warfare
from 1998 to 1991 wasn't pretty was very
ugly
led to a full-on war in the early 90s
full-on war
and in the late 90s 1991 to 1992
uh armenians in karabakh were targeted
for months-long
campaign of intentional civilian
bombardment and blockade by azerbaijan
shelling sniper shooting aerial attacks
killed and maimed hundreds of civilians
you know wounded hurt them a lot
uh ceasefire signed in 1995 by 1994
uh that brought two decades of uh you
know
war that's going on back and forth a
little bit to stability this is 1994
okay 1994 which is
26 years ago april 2016
there was a four day escalation again
war ugliness for four days
very ugly going back and forth that
people dying
left and right the deadliest ceasefire
violation until
2020 crisis which is now so now it's
been
nine days we have two sides one side
azerbaijani president uh ilya aliyev
who's done a lot of different interviews
lately
he is saying this is our land this is
ours they're not going to get it and if
you want to come get it we're not going
to let you have it armenia on the other
side
uh is saying that azerbaijan attacked
first
and they started this our mini has to
defend themselves and pashinian prime
minister listen we're not going to sit
here and let you do whatever you want to
do to our people we have to defend our
people
so they've gone back and forth and it's
very technical it's very complicated
you know there is on one end you got
armenia
that is somewhat protected by russia you
know the prime minister has had
conversations with the prime minister of
france
the leaders of iran twice he talked to
putin prime minister pashinyan has
and russia kind of protects armenia and
somewhat iran protects
armenia as well because they're right
there in the caspian sea and then
azerbaijan is protected by
turkey and also a little bit of israel
because the oil business that they have
and turkey because
turkey is muslim armenia is 96
christian azerbaijan is 91 muslim
population to population i think armenia
is 2.9 million
azerbaijan is 10.3 million armenia's
military budget is like 1.7 billion
azerbaijan's military budget annuals
like 2.9 billion it's twice the amount
of military budget
so azerbaijan threatened to attack
armenia's nuclear plant this is going
back and forth it's not really pretty
some of the videos you see
are very very ugly on what's going on
but uh
russia can stop this but they can't they
haven't yet because they do business
with turkey and they sell them weapons
so they are a customer so there are
multiple parties that can stop this but
they haven't yet
u.s russia and turkey can stop this
rhino if they wanted to
but they haven't yet why each have their
own interest
u.s isn't because u.s asked armenia to
stop doing business with iran even
though we put sanctions you still
are and armenia says what do you want us
to do they're our neighbors
you want me to say no to them i share
caspian sea with these guys
right across it we're neighbors i have
to have good relation with my side
turkey isn't doing it because turkey's
never liked armenia you know turkeys
have wanted to make armenians disappear
for the longest time erdogan cannot
stand
armenians publicly criticize them
regularly
and then on the other side russia's kind
of in the middle saying listen man we're
kind of like the co-chair
and we're watching this with a couple
that different nation that with a coach
i can't fully get involved
but really they can't if russia us and
turkey wanted to stop this they could do
it today but they haven't yet
so that i got more things i want to talk
about with this but i'm going to turn it
over to you guys i know you guys have
done some research as well sure where
are you at what's going on
i don't claim to be an expert but you
know this thing's only nine or ten days
old but if you look at the
if you look at the history here's the
thing that scares me
turkey i mean they're the you mentioned
that the fact that they could they're
not going to
and they're right there and they're the
ones that are going to escalate this
thing and make it make it way worse
i'd love to see a situation where the us
would would step in
and help out i think that he could
probably take care of this rather
quickly
does the do the armenians have enough
support here to get the attention
of the people they need to to step in
and do something
because i could see one of these this
this is one of those battles that if you
don't have
the us getting involved i mean this is
going to get bloodier and deadlier and
go on and on and on unless someone steps
in
what do you think the end game is i mean
can
armenia can they defend themselves i
mean do they have the ability over the
long term
without some sort of assistance i don't
think so
not by themselves no because here's the
thing they need somebody to back them up
they 100 need somebody to back them up
azerbaijan is twice the size
military budget three times population
wise and turkey 100
has come out and said we're supporting
them no one has come out and say
we are fully supporting armenia like
turkey's supporting
right azerbaijan here's what you need to
know about militaries you know who's the
strongest military in the middle east
turkey turkey number one above everybody
exactly so you got the biggest military
back in europe
you need somebody of a superpower to
back you up and armenia hasn't had that
yeah but i know for a fact
both both the u.s and russia can stop it
armenia just went into a dealing with
china 15 billion investment going into
armenia so uss trump is probably not too
comfortable with that
and the bigger concern for us is more
iran than it is anything else
yeah yeah i think the the
the biggest thing that i'm seeing here
is because you know
you might have people being saying well
what do i care about armenia
azerbaijan i've never even heard of
azerbaijan why what is it
what happened in world war one did you
really care about what happened in
hungary and austria hungary and
and serbia but the potential for a
powder keg is what scares me
this is right in the middle east if you
don't know where armenia is and
azerbaijan
it's just north of iran just south of
georgia which is bordering russia
just uh east of turkey
right can you pull off the map yeah
let's pull up a map but the last thing
that we need here
is a powder keg to go off and the
entanglement that's going on i mean you
you were trying to explain it you have
turkey supporting azerbaijan you have
iran that's playing on both sides you
have
you have us here then you have russia
that's kind of playing both sides
israel has uh relations with azerbaijan
because they've sold them weapons and
they have oil but now you have people
in israel saying we can't support these
people we can't do this the
the the biggest concern for me is this
guy erdogan and turkey
this guy is a strong man of strong men
okay and he's just trying to consolidate
power
and he's gonna be the uh president of
turkey for quite some time
and the rhetoric that comes out of his
mouth is actually crazy
and then you have the um how do you say
his name ilham aliyev
yep this guy so the q i've looked at
some of his quotes and these are the
types of quotes these are the types of
the way you have to tweet up kai yeah do
you have his tweet i'm gonna read that
this is the type of thinking that is
very
very dangerous i wait for you to pull it
up kai he says armenia is not even a
colony
it is not even worthy of being a servant
this is a president of
of azerbaijan yeah this is the type of
mentality
that that you can't even respect your
bordering country
you can't even respect your fellow man
they're not even worthy of being a
servant this is like
this is like when uh you have the
iranian um
the people that run iran what do you
call them the cheeks what are they what
are the people who
lost the mullahs who says like death to
america they are
less than rodents like this type of talk
this type of mentality is
very very dangerous somebody needs to
step in
and whether it's united states i don't
know if it's trump's responsibility or
if this is mike pompeo
secretary of state somebody needs to
step in and
end this conflict before it gets out of
hand and this powder keg explodes in the
middle of the freaking
craziest place on the planet the middle
east
sure okay i gotta imagine the armenians
feel incredibly vulnerable
and on an island like no one's there to
support them right
are they susceptible to china doing more
could china see this
as a way to escalate tension about that
just the other day yes they can see this
as an opportunity for them
to win that's how i right yeah so my
exactly where you're going is a concern
here's one thing you need to know about
armenians
armenians they're not going to back down
period you know if you go back to
history
i'm half armenian half a syrian you know
what's the debate on both sides which
one's the first christian
armenians say they're the first
christian the syrians said they're first
christians but
historically you know say armenians are
the first christians
they are some of the proudest people
you'll ever meet okay
smartest proudest the silicon valley of
russia is in
armenia they are producing some of the
best engineers when we're hiring
engineer firms and we want to hire uh uh
folks to do
coding for us you you're gonna guess
your best best of the best is gonna be
in armenia for you today
and this is not just me telling you this
you can go around the nation and talk to
people that are hired to produce stuff
for you they're gonna say
we have our engineers working for us
from armenia
they're building that kind of a
reputation for themselves right now in
armenia however
um unfortunately they are in a situation
right now
that they need allies they need somebody
to come in and help them out
and it has to be if u.s comes out
and says hey turkey what are you doing
defending azerbaijan
it is a form of defending the armenian
genocide erdogan has said
if you come out and say armenian
genocide
is an event that actually happened we're
going to go ahead and make sure whatever
we can do to eliminate your three
military bases that you have in turkey
and armenia u.s has three military bases
in turkey the the
most complicated personality is exactly
who you said
is erdogan listen they can't stand
armenians
they cannot stand armenians to save
their lives
if there is a nation that they cannot
stand it is armenians
but if there is a nation that i can tell
you from personal knowing the history
you you got fighters above fighters
they're not going to back down
there's no way in the world armenia is
going to back down and
you're starting to kind of see a glimpse
of it all over the place by the way
here's what's interesting
do you know once the last time the two
of them were in the same room together
like negotiating right do you know
when's the last time they were in the
same room together
type in uh type in uh elieve
and paschinya it wasn't that long ago
wasn't it was a year a year and a half
ago
uh uh if you know how to pronounce uh
spell the name
uh right there type in uh uh and then
type in uh
uh aliyev look at the just go down and
that name will pop up kai just go down
that name will pop
up okay good and then type in next to
paschinian
pashinyan january 19 to 20 i think
january 22nd
press images images
gen right there that's january 22nd 2019
they were at the uh
uh davos together having a conversation
a year and a half later who is this
right here that's that's eliav and
that's paschinya
that's armenia prime minister and that's
the president of azerbaijan
a year ago year and a half ago they're
sitting there having a conversation
together okay look at that can you tell
how comfortable that is
yeah the on the right is our armenia on
the left is azerbaijan
he looks exactly like erdogan by the way
here's the craziest thing check this out
his background just so you know little
details pashini's background
he was a journalist okay
the first company he came out with as a
journalist a year later they shut it
down
then he ended up working for armenia
times for quite some time
and when he was writing he came out
publicly
uh disagreeing with uh uh disagreeing
with the way
uh the president the military uh leader
at the time was doing
because of that he went to jail for one
year so he ended up going to jail
okay he comes back he's writing for
armenia times as he's going about his
business
and he gets controversial he doesn't
support the first president he supports
the second president
eventually he ends up running democracy
all this stuff
and the closest comparison i'm going to
make to him is trump
let me explain to you why this will kind
of make sense to you so
he's being interviewed by bbc and the
guy from bbc asked him he said the
reporter from bbc
asks then says why is it that ever since
you got elected
there's so much protesting and writing
going against you he says because
under democracy you can protest against
me
prior to me you couldn't protest against
the president i want to allow democracy
so they're not okay but why is it that
when
the the the the what do you call it
they're coming out and telling you
that you cannot be oh so back and forth
here you go
he comes on and says why is it that the
u.n general assembly demands the
immediate complete exit
of all armenian forces for from the
occupied territories of republic of
azerbaijan how come you haven't listened
to it
he says i'm not going to let armenia is
being killed okay what do you want us to
do you want us to
sit around this guy is a true believer
of bringing democracy in armenia then
they bash him because of covet
they said why is it that the number of
cases you had is six times more than
georgia
and way more than azerbaijan every
single criticism he's getting
is the one that trump had every single
more protesting hey you're getting more
protesting
more covet how you're getting more
covered you're not handling it well
right every single
he went to a party that was taking place
uh during covet and it was 600 people
there nobody was wearing a mask and
everybody's like
wait a minute how come you didn't have a
mask on he says because the region i
wasn't you didn't have to you didn't
have to wear a mask and on the complete
opposite side armenia since 1994 has had
four presidents
armenia since 1994 has had four
presidents do you know the same family
has led azerbaijan since 1994. let me
say this
imperialist exactly so you got nepotism
imperialism
essentially since 94 azerbaijan armenia
for presidents democracy since 1994.
people are choosing their leader
azerbaijan the people are not choosing
their leader
so pashini is making the argument saying
listen the people voted me in
but not on azerbaijan the families voted
people in so what's this guy's story
yeah
he's uh he's from the family lineage you
know he comes from the family lineage
and
when you're coming from the family
lineage you're almost like the same one
coming up and
yes yes and his arguments are completely
different arguments says listen this is
our land what do you want us to do leave
our land we own this land
and the land that is in question is
karabakh yes
and for thousands of years armenia owned
the land but after stalin in 1923
uh i think it's 23. yeah in 1923 he said
no we're going to make it over here
to be controlled but the armenians can
live i think the population is 18
armenian by the way
in uh uh karabakh 18 is armenian yeah
that's it
yeah it's not as big as you think but it
is about 18 19 percent armenian i
believe that's true i want to say one
thing and this is something that i've
learned and i got to give a shout out to
my friend
tigram becky and we've had many
conversations about uh
everything that's going on here
something you know that that's near and
dear to me
is obviously being jewish the holocaust
right in the 1940s
everything happened with hitler and that
is obviously you know the
what people the go-to story
about genocide that was world war ii but
what people
failed to realize is during world war
one right before that
there was an armenian genocide on the
hands of the ottoman empire turkey
which correct me if i'm wrong they fail
to recognize
they won't even admit wrongdoing this is
something that turkey will not
own up to one thing that i respect about
germany is they've owned up to it i mean
they they have not taken down the
concentration camps
they tell people to come visit they you
know they will not allow nazi symbols in
in germany
they know that they messed up obviously
times a billion
what is it with turkey that they won't
even own up to the fact that they've
created
this genocide yeah and then you're
vulnerable to repeat history
right when you have the exact same
beliefs you know this is a comment that
kind of relates to this but
i i wish this would come up in the
debates but listen to the names that
we've thrown out here in just this
conversation
china iran russia turkey u.s our biggest
problem in the country
this country right now and i wish they
would address it in the in the debates
is
we we don't know who our enemies are we
think it's the democrats for the
republicans or the republicans for the
democrats that's all we spend our time
on
with this bickering and i just believe
this division that we have in this
country
is being manufactured very good point
you know by these bigger superpowers
and if we get thrust into this thing
it's going to be big
because when you look at all the players
that are involved and the area that it's
in and that's the biggest problem with
this country is
we just don't identify we don't really
truly know and identify who our real
enemies are yeah why don't we do that
go ahead why don't we do that right now
who's number one let's stay on this
let's stay on this point here because i
do want to answer your question because
you asked and said
armenian german germany came out and
said you know hey
we did it okay but they paid a massive
price for it
i think their last payment of
reparations was just in 2018 or some
number like that it's just
recently they got them paying off for
all the reparations
and i talked to aram hamparian who works
out of dc representing the armenian
community
do you know what's the number armenia is
going to ask of turkey
if they say the genocide did take place
trillion dollars it's in the trillions
of dollars
this is very basic for them they don't
want to pay reparations
simple as that trillion is a big number
okay you're not talking about a small
number here
it's reparations when the genocide took
place there was a whole insurance scam
going on behind closed doors of
the insurance the people that were dying
their policies that's a whole different
story that had to do with turkey wanting
to get
even more money on the insurance
policies but this is a very
very ugly thing that took place and
all that needs to happen is america
needs to say
it is an event that took place congress
agreed to it senate agreed to it
it went all the way to up to uh
president president said no earlier this
year
and uh uh it's it's uh but again this
year this year yeah this just trump said
no
it's either this year or it's december
but it's in less than 12 months so what
happened with that unpack that
exactly what i just told you yeah turkey
is an ally of course
if turkey becomes an enemy nato you lose
all control in the middle east
so the only thing if trump comes out
obama said he'll do it he didn't do it
when he became president
every one of these guys had said they're
going to do what they haven't done when
they became president no one's ever done
it
since they've been president bush all of
them have said it this is an event that
happened to win the armenian vote
no one said yes yet but if trump says
yes
he wins the three million whatever the
amount of people that he's going to win
over right
but he's going to lose turkey and
turkey's a
much more needed ally for him in the
middle east it's unfortunate but that's
how he's processing it
it's not that it didn't happen but i can
tell you one thing it's a money deal
and turkey does not want to pay the
trillions of dollars that they're going
to pay especially in today's money and
it may take them 100 years to pay it off
by the way
this is not like reparations for germany
against the you know the jewish
community
how how long for the world
92 years world war one though that
wasn't uh yeah but
you're talking about uh i'm talking
about uh
uh nazi germany 1941.
okay last one was paid 2010 2010 i mean
that's game changing for two economies
no one paying anyone receiving it
exactly so that's the part you have to
realize with that going on so
anyways uh folks if you're watching this
what we're going to be doing is i'll
make an announcement here with what's
going on i'll keep i know the armenian
community they message me all the time
on instagram
all over the place i'm getting given
text right now for some of my peers
i want you to know we're in
communication with their camp
uh you know if if my suggestion is a
long form interview to be able to do
with the
armenian pm uh and they can reach out to
us i know even the azerbaijani community
has reached out saying what if
wants to do an interview with you would
you be open to it i'm open to
figuring out a way to stop this ninth
day so it doesn't continue to tempt a
because i saw videos the other day my
friend steve sent me a video kai do you
have that video that i just sent you
can you put it up just to just to kind
of see uh
it's not the worst video i almost
thought about it whether i wanted to
show it or not
but uh you know some of the words he's
saying uh
if kai can get this this is probably
in armenian it's the worst
uh uh possible words you can be saying
uh let's see if kai can find it
shout out to steve while we pull up his
clip steve steven
yeah good boy shout out to rafi's place
if you're in l.a go check that out all
right check this out look at this this
is armenian soldiers
turn that up okay they're they're
walking and they're seeing what the
other
johnny military did to their people
by the way if you're armenian you're
listening you've got kids you may not
want your kids to listen to this the
profaner is pretty
these are all bodies on the side by the
way i don't know
this is what's going on right now we're
not seeing these are our bodies on the
side
and this continues by the way if you
want to pause it you get the idea
yeah i mean he just curses mother out
for what they're doing so this is
that was which military this is just
this is armenian military
yeah that is going seeing their soldiers
killed
armenian soldiers killed of what
azerbaijan did to them i mean it's a
very
um the the one the one instagram i'm
going to give a
shout out to to go follow uh
uh the uh the population in art stock is
99 armenia today
the uh the lower numbers back when the
yes that's right the population arsoc is
99 armenia today
back when it was to azerbaijan it was 18
armenia but today it's 99 percent
armenian arsakh that community okay
that's that's the stuff that i saw so
let me let me give you
a one instagram profile zarton
k media if you can post these guys link
below
i kind of want these guys to get uh some
love because
they're getting people to follow their
stories very closely and i'll give you
another update as well with the stories
for people to follow okay so we're
getting the last six minutes here gang
um this is the most we've ever had on a
podcast we've never had any other
number that's bigger than this except
for the debate outside of the debate
that's the first time we've cracked 3000
people ever i think the highest was 2700
we cracked 3119 and i'm glad you're
enjoying this listen we're having fun
with this as well
you're bringing us just as much energy
as we're bringing to you so believe it
or not your commentary is
helping out your uh uh energy is helping
out we're feeling it there's a couple
announcements i want to make here let me
make the first announcement that we've
been working on
here for quite some time so with
valuetainment as you guys can see this
whole thing started off with a channel
being called patrickbetdavid
when we got to forty thousand
subscribers i decided to change it to
valuetainment
i thought i came out with an original
name come to find a way tim it was a
publicly traded company in germany
i got a contact with the ceo his name is
dirk i asked him for the domain i wanted
to buy it he said i'll give it to you
for 500
000 but i'm a publicly traded company i
said i just want you know we're building
a company and i want that name he says
i'm not going to sell it to you for what
you want
but i give it to you for 500 000 long
story short three years later he changes
the company name
from valuetainment to valuets ies so
it's still there
we end up buying the domain a couple
years ago for a good number but
definitely not a half a million dollars
so we on vitetamin.com and when we
started valuetainment.com it wasn't
about patrick bay david you have your
own opinions
you know you come and you're anti-trump
and you don't like what he does and you
have certain opinions but you're
reasonable you can talk and
you don't seem like you're crazy you're
just kind of giving your opinions or
experience where you're at and
great you have your own show now victim
and economics you're doing great people
are loving your content every week show
is coming out with you
tom zenner now has been working with us
now i think it's what four weeks six
weeks i don't know the exact timeline i
think it's about four weeks
you've been on the podcast several times
people love having you you've had your
background on what you've done with
media
we got a team now we're making videos
daniel demartino booth is now creating
content
we got a lot of other people that are
coming along with the audience as well
and and we're constantly looking for new
talent to bring on board that matches
that value to me you got to bring value
but you got to be entertained you got to
bring value but you got to be
entertaining then you'll donate a value
but you got to be entertaining you got
to have that valuetainment
dna the most recent edition that we're
adding to valuetainment which is very
very exciting we've been very excited
about this for a while
we have officially made it uh we
finalized the agreement
general spalding is the latest talent
that we are adding to valuetainment
general spalding of the air force that
we did a few interviews his experience
of living in china multiple times
and going there as a one-star general he
now officially has a show on
valuetainment called
generally speaking which will be
conducting interviews and giving us
updates and i cannot wait
for him because his background he's i
think he landed here already i don't
know if he's already at the office
is he already here or not if he can text
mario he may be here right now
him and daniel are about to have a
meeting to get at the office but general
spalding is officially going to be a
content creator on valuetainment we are
very very excited
uh to have them on here with us general
spalding so
that's exciting to announce his show
will be coming out here very soon
and outside of that with general
spalding the other announcement i do
want to make to everybody is the fact
that while this entire time
things have been going on news is being
shared we decided to come out
with our own news site kai if you can
give me the mouse
uh uh and the keyboard so i can kind of
show the folks if you want to go to the
site and then i'll take over with the
keyboard
we are officially this morning launching
our own news site called
vtpost.com let me say this one more time
we are launching a new site called
vtpost.com the go-to
new site for busy people and the reason
why we came up with this is because
look i don't have time when i'm running
a company i got all these different
things i'm doing i don't have time to
sit there and watch news for two hours
three hours i need news to be quick
and if you're somebody that watches
vitamin you're probably somebody as well
that doesn't have all the time in the
world
vt post is built specifically for busy
people
okay so it's going to be slightly
different uh our editor-in-chief is
going to be
tom zenner right here who's been in this
world for quite some time i think he
said what 26 years yeah
45 years it's a long time uh that you've
been with a lot of experience
and you get different kind of headlines
when you come here the story after
circus-like debate biden says he regrets
clown around clowning around
and you'll have headlines you'll have
business you'll have politics you'll
have lifestyle you have entertainment
pop culture
i mean it'll show you stuff if you go to
here uh uh
you know houses you can rent we'll have
cigars we'll have
after hours enjoying life ballers sports
uh a lot of different things that you
can come with a new site
that you look at it doesn't matter what
interests you the most whether you want
to go see what's going on with sports
whether you want to see
this house that jeter and brady own
that's on sale right now for 28 million
dollars
and details on that whether you want to
find out updates on
what's going on with trump or maybe you
want to go see the top five stories
today we have it all
here for you on valuetainmentvtpost.com
tom i think you want to say something
well pat thanks for the opportunity and
i think a lot of people are looking for
something like this right now and we've
really spent a lot of time building this
thing for the people that
are busy and you don't have a lot of
time but once you come here i think
you're going to spend some time here now
we wanted to write our stories
in in a flashy way but in in a in a way
that doesn't waste your time 250 to 300
words
you get all the information you need and
you move on you're gonna know what's
going on in the day
but we wanted to have our own
personality our own edge and our own
voice with this so like if you go to
ballers that's gonna be the category for
pop culture sports and entertainment
we're not doing scores
no one cares about that we're gonna tell
you about the brawl at the end of the
football game we're going to tell you
about
you know chris pratt being in trouble
for what he uh put out on instagram
and our news flash i want you to really
pay attention to our headlines too
because we try to have some fun with
them
we try to draw you in and there are
plenty of new sites out there we get
bombarded with it all day i think it's
one of the biggest problems in this
country is they're the gloom and doom
factor they're trying to scare the crap
out of people
24 7. we don't do that we want to be fun
we want to be optimistic but we also
want to tell you what's going on in the
world
we're not going to be biased we're going
to rely on common sense
and and i think you're going to have
some fun on this site so come check it
out today
come every day make sure you sign up for
our newsletter
and stay connected with us follow us on
all the social media platforms that we
have and we're going to keep you updated
yep exactly and by the way last but not
least here's the last but not least that
i want to share with everybody that's
watching as well
we are looking for contributors it's
that simple
we are looking for contributors like
this article here written
art stock right to self-determination
held hostage by azaria expand
expansionism written by von der
megerdiche an ucla graduate
who's currently going to columbia
university for journalism he writes
what's going on there's a timeline to it
and there's going to be
updates on specifically what's going on
with armenia but we are looking for
contributors and what we are doing with
our contributors just so everybody
understands to apply for it
when you do apply to be a contributor
and you write articles we will be
sharing your articles
on valuetainment on twitter
on our valuetainment facebook page on if
the story is a good story and you have
an audience as well we'll put it on
instagram
but we're going to give you a lot of
exposure as well for yourself and
there'll be different levels
anybody that writes three articles
you'll get recognition on the homepage
scroll anybody writes 25 articles we're
going to give you recognition on vt post
video
specifically recognizing the new
contributor that's written 25
contributors anyone that writes 100 you
get a 25 amazon gift card
and anyone that contributes 500 articles
you'll be invited to
exclusive vip parties that will put
together with the valuetainment audience
you'll get a chance to meet a lot of
different people so if you want to apply
to be a contributor simply go to
contributors on the site go to apply
and then uh once you're able to uh get
approved by the team the team will
respond back to
uh uh recognize you then your stories
will be here by contributors on the home
page
and people will be following your
content as well so having said that
two announcements general spalding new
talent on valuetainment we're very
excited about that and on top of that
vt post that we are launching today if
you haven't yet
visited vtpost.com kaif we can put the
link below
go to vtpost.com give us a visit
give us a shout out and we'll give you
daily news 20 new stories
every single day everything that is
going on
congratulations
definitely definitely again by the way
he had a flat tire everything was going
against yesterday but we are here
i literally have a flat tire in the
morning one o'clock in the morning we're
texting but we're here we're launching
it so gank
uh thank you for being with us until
next time today is what tuesday i think
we are doing it again this thursday
next podcast and we are thinking about
still thinking about
doing a live on the next debate if it
does happen on the 15th we are listening
to you if you want to see it comment
below and tell us yes
if you haven't subscribed yet do so put
a thumbs up and go visit our website
take care everybody bye bye bye bye bye
go eat tonight guys
go eat tonight
you